sie alle wollen auf und davon
christine schönbächler und ihr mann
hermann sie ziehen mit ihren kindern
regie und natascha nach kanada anja
kinski und claude wegmann wollen sich in
italien eine existenz aufbauen mit dabei
ist kino der trüffel und anni kuhn und
orlando stamm geben ihrer jungen liebe
ein neues zuhause auf bali bauen sie
eine ferienanlage jennifer wettstein
yaman ali und söhnchen sven versprechen
sich in peru eine bessere zukunft in
lima sollen ihre träume wahr werden
[Musik]
erzählt eine mutter die stunden die sie
in ihrem leben auf ihren sohn wartet was
zählt ist das gefühl dass sie dabei
empfindet und dieses ist zu beginn fast
immer freudige erwartung elisabeth
schönbächler erwartet in kloten ihren
sohn hermann aus kanada der bap ist
tatsächlich weg der holzfäller hermann
schönbächler hat ihn vor seiner abreise
aus kanada abrasiert in peru haben sich
ali und jenny wettstein ein letztes mal
fest gedrückt bevor der schweizer sich
für drei monate verabschiedete
in italien musste sich claude wegmann
bereits durch allerlei hindernisse
schlagen
während die kinski schwestern sich um
zwei aufgaben kümmerten und in bali
bereiteten anni kuhn und orlando stammen
die einweihungszeremonie ihres
ferienresorts vor
es ist kurz vor elf am flughafen kloten
nach der person ist schon eigentlich
lang vertraut seit einem halben jahr
lebt herrmann mit seiner familie in
kanada
jetzt besuchte er die schweiz kein sohn
dieser welt freut sich nicht darauf hin
und wieder zur mutter zurück zu kehren
auch hermann ist beim wiedersehen guter
laune des nordatlantik
[Applaus]
es ist nicht das ich nicht dass harry co
es ist gut da hier ja was ist das
hessisches bot gar verrückten kanada im
grunde muss mir die wochen oder auch
hier zutage
ekstatisch auch mit jetzt dafür hier
bliebe der ist einfach mehr in arbeit
suchen
ja es ist es die stars das ist das genau
ja
ja genau mutter und sohn und mehr liebe
als man denkt
[Musik]
hier in den wäldern von hra suite ist
hermann wirklich zu hause
doch jetzt ist christine schönbächler
allein mit ihren kindern dar
drei wochen lang wird das so sein
bayerisches landes ist jetzt versteh
handbuch ist dass ich das einmal weg ist
hoch dass wir das ist
[Musik]
seit einem halben jahr wohnt der werber
claude wegmann in italien seine
partnerin anja kind gearbeitet aus
finanziellen gründen immer noch in der
schweiz besucht ihn aber wenn immer
möglich in ihren künftigen zuhause
anja hat zwei freundinnen aus
deutschland mitgebracht
christine und tula claude ist mal wieder
der hahn im korb
heute will er mit den dreien hühner
kaufen
[Musik]
anja und claude arbeiten seit anfangs
jahr an der verwirklichung ihres traums
sie möchten in zwei jahren ihr
agriturismo eröffnen ein hof mit tieren
eigenem garten und mit zimmern die sie
an gäste vermieten wollen
sie kommen
[Musik]
fehlt eigentlich wirklich erst gut aus
wir waren ja auch mal auf dem markt
gewesen und da hatten sie für auch
hühner in den so ein gefährt die sagen
ein gewisser gut aus haben viele gedern
gefehlt und die machen mir jetzt einen
gesunden eindruck ich muss zugeben ich
habe nicht so wahnsinnig viel ahnung von
dem thema fürs erste genügen anja und
claude vier hühner die kosten zusammen
knapp 20 euro
später wollen sie noch mehr kaufen
[Musik]
schwer
[Applaus]
bis zehn kilo ich hoffe dass die länger
leben als sei trage sie stiegen mit
david kommen
[Musik]
in der peruanischen metropole lima leben
siebeneinhalb millionen menschen genau
gleich viele wie in der ganzen schweiz
doch einer fehlt jenny wettstein und zu
uns wenn wir müssen seit wochen ohne ali
auskommen
es ist das erste mal dass die zwei
alleine sind seit die junge familie vor
acht monaten aus der schweiz
ausgewandert ist
jenny ist peruanerin ali hat sie hier in
lima vor acht jahren kennen gelernt
sie folgte ihm nach bayern wo sie
heirateten und sven zur welt kam
die nächsten drei monate muss jenny
nicht nur allein für sven sondern auch
zur pasta fabrik und zum restaurant
schauen drei monate so lange wird ali
10.500 kilometer entfernt von jenny und
sven leben zurzeit arbeitet der gelernte
haustechnik installateur in ittigen bei
bern auf dem bau ein ganzer sommer ohne
familie für 6500 franken im monat auf
dauer ist das keine lösung optionen
würde sich nicht unbedingt diese option
des nächsten jahres und so weiter und so
fort
[Musik]
die drei monate sind zum glück bald
vorbei denn auch wenn vermisst seinen
papa sehr
ich glaube da noch immer ganz fertig
jaja papier pappe therme und der musik
des 19
sie stiegen
[Musik]
der große tag im kleinen fischerdörfchen
damit in bali alle sind gekommen um bei
der einweihung des neuen ferienresorts
dabei zu sein
schon vor monaten wurde der termin
festgelegt denn der balinesische
kalender verspricht für heute glück und
wirtschaftlichen erfolg
[Musik]
ein heiliger mann ein brahmanen leitet
die zeremonie und segnet alle anwesenden
seit dem baubeginn im herbst fiebern
aniko und orlando stammen diesen tag
entgegen
[Musik]
für orlando den ehemaligen
vermessungsingenieur aus graubünden und
seine partnerin anni die ehemalige
hauswirtschaftslehrerin aus der
ostschweiz war immer klar dass sie an
dieser zeremonie aktiv teilnehmen würden
alles andere wäre von den einheimischen
after götter insel bali nicht verstanden
worden
spätestens als liegt zubereiteten
opfergaben verspeist werden stört es
niemanden mehr dass die ferienanlage
noch gar nicht fertig ist und deshalb
nicht eröffnet werden kann
allein die anwesenheit des
gemeindepräsidenten unterstreicht die
bedeutung der feier für die dorfbewohner
[Musik]
sich eigentlich den sack zu als weiblich
und alles ist böse und das ist jetzt er
glaube allerdings dass alle häuslichen
zeichnet und schutz vor dem gewitter ist
jetzt schwer leicht sehr leicht sich
sehr wichtig
das böse kann man ihn natürlich haben
die chinesische kultur und an der
zeremonie jetzt die chance schon in die
welt gesetzt also das machen bereich der
zeremonie er sich die kultur und die
religion dauert eben akzeptieren
in kanada ist es rund ums haus der
familie schönbächler noch ein wenig
ruhiger als sonst
es sollen keine motorsägen christine ist
mit den kindern natascha und ricky
allein diese wurden baum und blieb der
[Musik]
die tage mit den kindern vergehen wie im
flug die abende ganz allein in der neuen
heimat sind für die 37 jährige
schweizerin aber einsam im selben
augenblick in der schweiz bereitet sich
ihr mann auf seinen wettkampf vor
hermann schönbächler ist einer der
favoriten an der holzfäller schweizer
meisterschaft 2010 in den flumserbergen
hier messen sich an diesem wochenende im
juni zwei dutzend weitere handwerker in
sechs disziplinen
[Musik]
der start in den wettkampf gelingt
hermann zwar nicht ganz nach wunsch doch
ist nicht verloren denn kaum einer hat
mehr erfahrung und bereitet sich
gewissenhaft davor als der
kanada-schweizer dass er ist
[Musik]
als sich hermann schönbächler auf den
nächsten einsatz vorbereitet liegt er
zwar auf medaillenkurs allerdings hinter
seinem stärksten konkurrenten bereits
seit die kämpfe weiter ich brauch seines
kriegenburgs extra wohngebiete 120
sekunden neue das mächtige waffe wie 11
246 menschen
zum 15
[Applaus]
und plötzlich wittert hermann seine
gewinn chance als er zum kampf in die
arena steigt sieht er dass sein größter
widersacher die regeln verletzt hat
gewissenhaft meldete dies umgehend den
schiedsgericht das ist aber eine
disqualifikation mit seiner einsprache
erreicht hermann schönbächler dass das
resultat des konkurrenten in dieser
disziplin gestrichen wird
und jetzt den sieg vor augen hält ihn
nichts mehr zurück
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hermann schlägt sich mit allen ihm zur
verfügung stehenden mitteln zum sieg zu
einem sieg der bei ihm jedoch einen
bitteren nachgeschmack hinterlässt
[Musik]
jaja aber deutlich nicht schon im
grundsatz für in der schlussphase
disqualifiziert
das ist nicht schön erinnert besiegen
ich schon aber mit disqualifikation
hermann führt die rangliste nach fünf
von sechs durchgängen an
in der abschluss disziplin hat so der
heißen säge lässt er nichts mehr
anbrennen und setzt sich durch
[Musik]
dass sie genug zeit unter wasser
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit dem fünften schweizer meistertitel
in den händen ruft er seine familie in
kanada anja gute tag wollten ja wohl ja
ja ja ja ja ja
[Musik]
in italien haben die vier hühner die
kurze fahrt in der schachtel gut
überstanden
aus dem geplanten hühnerstall in einem
der gebäude ist allerdings nichts
geworden
der umbau wäre zu aufwendig gewesen
kurzerhand hat claude eine hölzerne
unterkunft gekauft loslegen 100
pfannkuchen mit den rechtlichen und dann
legt er los
zum gratulieren sich hinter dem
zuzuschauen bauen angespannt hoffen wir
mal dass der fuchs nicht hier demnächst
ein blutbad anrichtet nacht sind sie ja
in dem häuschen und da kann vermutlich
eher nichts passieren und tagsüber meist
halt die hoffnung dass dadurch dass das
einigermaßen zentrales und wir ja auch
hier immer in der gegend sind dass da
jetzt nicht unbedingt der fuchs
vorbeikommt
langsam nimmt formen an das kleine
agriturismo in den hügeln von santa dino
die ersten tiere zu haben das ist jetzt
natürlich schön weil wir wollen ja hier
tiere haben und mitschülern haben wir
jetzt noch überhaupt keine erfahrungen
aber das macht spaß auch schauen ob das
funktioniert und dann irgendwann eigene
eier zu haben vielleicht schon morgen
[Musik]
das restaurant della nonna in lima hat
einen frischen anstrich bekommen neue
werbung neue möbel aber noch immer das
alte problem ins restaurant kommen die
gäste nur spärlich
zwar schätzen es die kunden das genie in
der abwesenheit ihres mannes ali für
neuen schwung gesorgt hat doch noch
immer muss die 33-jährige auf bessere
zeiten hoffen
bessere zeiten die spätestens dann
anbrechen sollen wenn ihr ali wieder
zurück in beruf ist denn der hat
monatelang weit weg in der schweiz
gearbeitet nur per computer telefonie
konnte er seine familie hin und wieder
sehen
[Musik]
jenny schildert ihre man die aktuellsten
schelmen streiche von sven die sie in
den letzten tagen erlebt hat ja ich hab
dich auf gehören aber dies tun wenn mama
die etwas sagt
[Musik]
das ist super dass technik sowie die
trainer so putzmunter und praktisch dass
die demo drüber weg das ist nicht
schlimm war es nicht was in den köpfen
ist es wenn du nicht mal an
[Musik]
die eröffnungsfeier muss den göttern der
insel gefallen haben denn offensichtlich
sind die arbeiten in den letzten wochen
besser vorangekommen
[Musik]
derweil dauern
als echter zusammen mit dem architekten
begehen anni kuhn und orlando stammen
die fertig gebaute anlage ist der boden
schon poliert es schaut nicht so aus er
möchte sauberer sein dass hier müsste
mehr poliert werden muss sich das hier
so bewegen lassen
aber hier müsste man das besser fixieren
[Musik]
wer in bali immer nur mit westlicher
logik an die dinge herangeht wird früher
oder später die erfahrung machen dass
hier an drei gesetzte geld nach wochen
die nerven gekostet haben sind anni und
orlando jetzt zwar müde aber auch stolz
so schön aber sie sind dabei
naja natürlich will jeder tag
sie macht hat aber mir wahnsinnig druck
machen breite markt bewirken
er macht nicht gemacht
das ist lästig und und volkan karlsruhe
sich kubica waren
[Musik]
das warten hat ein ende nach drei wochen
sehen christine schönbächler und ihre
kinder natascha und richtig
endlich papa hermann wieder
[Musik]
er sei hier in kanada seiner bestimmung
zugeführt worden hatte hermann zu einem
früheren zeitpunkt gesagt
und wer ihn bei seiner ankunft den
terrace im bundesstaat british columbia
im nordwesten kanadas strahlen sieht
will ihm glauben dass er mit seiner
familie hier sein wahres zuhause
gefunden hat
[Musik]
ein
dass hermann gepäck im gegensatz zu ihm
seinen bestimmungsort nicht gefunden hat
kümmert die familie in diesem augenblick
weniger
[Musik]
so hoch wie soll das gehen
was nicht einfach wenn wir schreien
müsst ihr unbedingt weg weil dann kommt
haben das nicht geschafft sie rauf zu
tun
ich weiß nicht was sich darauf stützen
stützten das jetzt ziemlich gut ich habe
angst nein ich geb geht gar nicht echt
wenn das jetzt hast du s klo tanja und
ihre beiden gäste stehen in italien
wieder einmal vor einer schwierigen
aufgabe stehen
wir drehen hier kein porno mit einem
pfosten rama der einen halben zentner
wiegt hat claude die pfeile alleine
schon mal richtig positioniert und
trotzdem scheinen die anwesenden damen
an seiner arbeitsweise zu zweifeln
nötig geworden war
ist mir persönlich zu wenig vorsichtig
wirklich also dass sabella dann
unbedingt und das muss dann gehen und da
versuche ich dann immer entgegen zu
wirken das ist das was ich meinte
[Musik]
drei monate lang musste jenny in lima
ohne ihre nani auskommen
heute kehrt er endlich nach hause zurück
klar dass sie ihren mann in mancher
situation vermisst hat sogar ganze set
für mich und ich ganz nach hinten
eine woche später ist okay was soll ich
jetzt machen auch der zweijährige sven
kann es kaum erwarten das papier wieder
da ist
allerdings zeigt er seine vorfreude auf
ein wenig andere art hallo das ist für
papa
2 hast du dich doch einfach da
hast du hast du hast schon das herz für
papa kaputt gemacht es reicht ja in rot
ist die familien idylle inzwischen
wieder hergestellt
außer dass hermanns koffer noch nicht da
sind kaum ist das tischgebet gesprochen
fährt ein auto der kanadischen
fluggesellschaft vor
tatsächlich das gepäck ist aufgetaucht
und hat seinen weg von paris nach ross
wird doch noch gefunden
gespannt schaut die familie was der papa
aus der schweiz alles mitgebracht hat
doch neben winkel und schrauben will
herrmann natürlich auch das symbol
seines erfolges präsentieren
das denkt wenn die festakt
ja ja ja ja ja wort werden
ihr müsst mir erst mal drauf habt ihr
ganz blöder sich eigentlich nur die
patente
[Musik]
37 hat sache für euch den regensburger
kommt
[Musik]
augen
loos nachteil weil ich auch durchsetzen
muss fliegt ja papa hermann ist mit
vielen geschenken zurück darüber freut
sich die ganze familie
fast die ganze familie denn christine
kann ihre leise enttäuschung über die
mitbringsel nicht verstecken
ja wenn man immer nur das bekommen würde
was man sich wünscht
dann wäre das ferien resort in bali
längst fertig dann hätten anni und
orlando nicht monatelang auf strom
warten müssen und dann saßen heute
wahrscheinlich schon die ersten gäste in
ihrem restaurant doch so stehen die
bungalows immer noch leer
immerhin lockt die anlage unbekannte
leute an
woher kommt ihr wir sind hier
vorbeigefahren und haben das resort
gesehen
ihr habt eine taufe ja und wir suchen
immer wieder unter künftig unsere
teilnehmer wenn ihr fertig seid und
gäste aufnehmen könnt dann meldet euch
dann können wir ins geschäft kommen
das sind holländer organisieren den
anscheinend jetzt gastland in im süden
somalias aufgesucht und die schicken
vielleicht ein paar liter motor heiraten
einmal inspiziert den einen quader fonds
eine frau mit der studie feststellt dass
man da wirklich innovative alle personen
mit denen vier stern der j-league
genannt
ja wer weiß vielleicht kommen dann auf
dauer das ist das ist sicher nicht
schlecht
oder auch das restaurant
[Musik]
in italien ist anja und load bisher
nichts geschenkt worden alles mussten
sie sich in den letzten monaten hart
erarbeiten
doch heute morgen soll dies anders sein
kunden brauchen die damen ja ich hab auf
eher weniger eier getippt ich meine dass
die irgendwie noch kamp stellen sind
hier ist schon mal nicht
naja könnten ruhig mal ein bisschen mehr
liegen meine damen also hier ist nicht
enttäuschend komme ich mal hier liegt 1
unser erstes sehr gut dann sehr gut ich
weiß nicht welche von euch es war sehr
schön der partitur und offensichtlicher
und das sehen sie in der nächsten folge
zu den hühnereiern kommt in italien
schon bald ziegenmilch anja und claude
kaufen wieder tiere in bali ist das
liebesglück von anni und orlando
vollkommen und die ersten gäste sind
endlich da
wiedersehen in peru ali jenny und sven
sind endlich wieder glücklich vereint
erfreuliche neuigkeiten aus kanada
christine trägt ein süßes geheimnis
unter dem herzen
doch nicht nur das deutet auf stürmische
zeiten hin
sehen sie ein finale voller emotionen
nächste woche auf und davon
das ist doch hier das einzige
[Musik]